Transcriber: Alia'a almakalh
المدقّق: Muhammad Samir
"موسيقى"
"تصفيق"
السلام عليكم جميعاً
أنا اسمي طه راجح
يشرفني أن اشارككم مجريات حياتي
التي اكملتها بنجاح
و التي ستشاهدونا في هذا الفيديو الذي سيعرض
وأتمنى أن تًلهم العديد من الناس
"تصفيق"
"موسيقى"
يشرفني أن أشارككم في مجريات حياتي
التي عديتها بنجاح والحمدلله
بداية حياتي في عام 93 ولدت
مصاباً بضمور في المخ،
ثم بعد ذلك تعالجت
ثم أجريت فحوصات طبية
في صنعاء، ثم ذهبت إلى صعده لتلقي
العلاج الطبيعي
في صعده كانت مدته ستة أشهر
ثم عدت الى صنعاء
ثم ذهبت إلى الأردن لتلقي العلاج
دخلت عند الدكتور أشرف الكردي الذي عالج
الرئيس ياسر عرفات رحمه الله
دخلت عند طبيب المخ والأعصاب
بعد ذلك أجريت فحوصات ضمور المخ
ثم أعطاني علاج ضمور المخ
واستخدمته بالدقائق والساعات
ثم بعد ذلك عدت لدكتور العظام،وهذه المره
كانت عوده
بعد ذلك قرر الدكتور إجراء العملية
بعد سنة لصغر سني
و كانت عملية رخ الاعصاب
لأني قبل العملية كنت امشي على اصابع اقدامي
فقرر الدكتور إجراء العملية
بعد سنة لصغر سني
رجعت الى اراضي الوطن
جلست سنة كاملة في صنعاء امارس
الرياضة
و بعد سنة عدت الى الأردن مرة ثانية
بعد ذلك أجريت عملية الأعصاب في أقدامي
ثم عدت بعدها أمارس الرياضة
و إكمال رحلتي التعليمية الى الصف الثامن
ثم سافرت الى الأردن بعد عشر سنوات
لإجراء عملية في المفصل و قرر الدكتور
عمل مسامير و صفيحة
بعدها عدت الى اليمن
جلست ثلاثة أشهر دون القدرة على الحركة
أتمنى الوصول الى قيادة الوطن ،
و طننا الغالي اليمن،سأكون خيراً لها
و سأكون عند حسن ظنكم، وظن وطني الحبيب
ثم تعلمت المشي و ممارسة الرياضة
لحد الآن أنا طالب جامعي و الفضل في هذا
يعود لله
من ثم بفضل الوالدين، و الحمدلله على كل شيء
"موسيقى"
"تصفيق"
شكراً
في الواقع، أنا الى هذه اللحظة معوق
لأن هناك بعض الناس يٌسيئون استخدام هذا
اللفظ
يعتبرونه بمثابت الشتم و الأستهزاء
و هذا لا يتفق مع دينٌنا الحنيف،
ولا مع أخلاقٌنا
"تصفيق"
فما أنصح به أخواني و أخواتي
هو التفاؤل بالخير،وحسن الظن ،و التوكل
على الله
فيما تخطوه و دائما علينا تنفيذ
كل ما تخطط له
افكارنا و خططنا على الواقع حتى نستطيع
التقدم وتحقيق أهدافنا وأحلامنا
وكل هذا لا يمكن حصوله إلا برضاء الله
والعمل الصالح و النية الحسنه
"تصفيق"
وأخيراً أتمنى التوفيق والنجاح للجميع
بشكل عام
وإخواني وأخواتي على وجه الخصوص
والسلام عليكم ورحمة الله وبركاته
"تصفيق"